hey guys I'm Ryan right Bradley so
Taylor and I today are gonna check out a
video from CollegeHumor called if
Facebook got rid of everything you hate
I don't know if I can handle that I need
things in my life to hate I know but I
feel like Facebook has a lot of things
but I dislike like poking or fat girls
in bikinis candy crush your Facebook's
next redesign we wanted to hear from you
we looked all your posts to find things
you don't like about Facebook and we fix
them you said there were too many ads so
we got rid of them pick here the cleaner
browsing experience than ever before you
said your feet was filled with
unreliable news sites and dumb jokes
written over stock photos posted by
radio stations so we've given you the
ability to report hoaxes and remove
sources you don't like up early posts
that are too serious
BuzzFeed posts that are too frivolous
both bands not seeing enough from your
close friends too much casual
acquaintances no problem we've revamped
our recommendation algorithms you only
see the people those people post wedding
or baby pictures
apparently you find those posts annoying
anyone who post wedding or baby pictures
will be banned on your timeline you
complained about people who leave a
status updates but also people who
overshare with incredible detail from
now on you'll only see posts that your
relatives have been obliterated
underneath you got too many invitations
in a stupid events you'll never go to
Sookie scrap that but you also didn't
want to suffer FOMO seeing other people
at parties and all references that
anything fun you also complained about
impersonal pictures of food and too
personal selfies
laughter this post about serious issues
and overblown post about she's really
interesting yeah Asian photos that make
you feel jealous and overworked new job
announcements that make you feel jealous
and lazy political post you agreed with
her preaching to the choir political
post who disagreed with were ignorant
diatribe you hated seeing stuff that was
stolen from reddit even though reddit
they look like somewhere else in the
first place so all that's gone - finally
we added that dislike button you've been
clamoring for and we can pray because no
one likes Craig the new Facebook it's
just a dislike button hi it's Mike Trapp
from CollegeHumor you know what I love
about CollegeHumor everything a lot of
very very much everything a lot of their
skits are sorry I don't why I'm like
leaning away from me [ __ ] away from me
doing a lot of their skits sort of stem
from a place of people being
unappreciative of what we have oh yeah
and like I think about Facebook or any
of these social networks it's kind of
like a cell phone like an iPhone is an
amazing invention oh yeah you can do
anything but we only talk about our
phones when we're complaining about them
it's too slow it's too this I have so
many pointless [ __ ] Wi-Fi my phone's
loading I know it's always dies you know
and I think about social networks and
how amazing it is how we have stuff like
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram that
allows us to be connected to so many
people globally and we could catch up
with friends that you've never thought
you would ever see again right you at
least get access to their Facebook and
you could say hi to them and it's an
awesome invention yes but it's also I
feel like people are also like
completely crumbling and changing the
way that they live their lives because
they're constantly trying to like push
themselves now and sell themselves as a
certain thing and so people take more
photos of these things that they're
doing and like oh look how interesting I
am look how fun my life is and it's like
even I am guilty of I'll go out to
dinner I'll be like oh I should probably
take a photo so the rest of the world
knows that I went out to dinner tonight
and I have stuff to do and it's like I
feel horrible about thinking that but I
still do yeah worst thing about Facebook
is they always take my dick pics down
yeah that's rough and I got a huge dick
so that's really rough it's really wrong
everybody else because you missed a
really great dick pic great thinking
about Facebook and like yes it certainly
has created its flaws with over you
with too much Facebook too much Twitter
too much Instagram any social network
it's become too much too much YouTube
okay what are you guys doing you I'm
gonna take it off the tube I'm I'm gonna
take an unpopular stance here good I
wonder though if people are actually
doing more with their lives now because
they feel the need to keep up with
everybody else
so I wonder if people are actually
experiencing and doing more you see
that's why I like this skin a lot though
because I don't believe most people I'm
sure there are some people who get
inspired or get motivated from like
jealousy or anger or something yeah but
when I see this it's like this is what
most people do when they go through
Facebook yeah they complain about
everything I think a lot of it might
even stem from a place of jealousy or
whatever so that's why people hate the
wedding and baby pictures is because
they're like I'm not there in my life
yeah I don't want to be there in my life
yet and so they feel all these negative
things but instead of being like damn
that's awesome so and so got married
this baby is flippin adorable especially
for girls cuz girls have a much harder
time with having to maintain it like I'm
[ __ ] like you know I'm YouTube fat
like in real life I'm not fat I'm
overweight so on YouTube gives people
you know this option to call me a fat
ass okay my girlfriend is [ __ ] hot as
hell yeah she is now normally with a guy
in girl's situation yeah you won't see
it the opposite way around girls have
more of a pressure for some for some
reason to be a bikini body style guys
can be whatever each other I think about
like those girls who like work out their
ass is so [ __ ] hard yeah then they do
a bikini shop because it's like they
want to show off so hard yeah but then
we'll scroll through and be like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] your pussy's bikini photo
because it inspires anger and other
people jealousy and all of these things
and so it's but instead of feeling like
positive for people I mean like wow
that's awesome you worked so hard you
know you have a handful of like their
best friends who say that and then
everybody else is angry because they
want that exactly exactly so rather than
letting ourselves be motivated by
finding a way to be inspired like if I
see a guy who's been working out who
used to be fat yeah I don't that inspire
me yeah I makes me go okay I should
probably work out more or something
it's not like the opposite if someone's
gaining success like if I get jealous it
motivates me to gain more success right
and that's how people should look at
Facebook I feel like and they're saying
that people don't look at it the right
way I mean there are some just really
annoying [ __ ] on of course there is like
all of those like guess what happens in
the next six seconds are like the kids
starts dancing what you'll happen what
happens next you'll never believe and
like ads to now I have to click on this
because I have to see what happens next
and then I do and it's never worth it
like some people will get so annoyed by
seeing posts when it's just like scroll
past the [ __ ] post right it takes you
one second and it's like the ads to it
can be annoying but they're not but the
ads are on the side so people will go to
their Facebook and instead of
appreciating what's good about it
they're gonna find all these things to
complain about so college humor is
really good at these kinds of skits
these are my favorite kind of skills
from that the real-life ones yeah yeah
ones that play I'm like how
unappreciated here we go that has some
kind of like deep philosophy yeah like
I'm so broke video we checked out yeah
like that one anyway guys thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
Taylor has a channel just started going
gung-ho with it you better check it out
ASAP it's really awesome
yeah quite a good amount of videos
already so check it out we can follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter where
we're hoping to get enough followers to
the point where we can get product
placement and like always I have not
prepared electronic cigarettes one of
the best ways to help you stop smoking
and go into denial that it's not doing
anything to you even though it does
contain nicotine get worse today the
best way to lie to yourself and tell
your friends that it doesn't do any harm
even though it hasn't been around long
enough to prove if it does harm or not
and it also comes in many different
flavors
Josh lioness hello real rejects you guys
are awesome I've only been around since
50,000 subscribers only been around
that's a while 70,000 subs like but you
guys rule
Ryan Jerry and Veronica you guys are my
favorite no offense to the others loser
with a capital L and a huge via pair you
hurt my feelings
Josh good thing she named her the V joke
by the way
Ryan's me reactions make me laugh so
hard damn it Ryan Josh lioness I am so
glad to have you as a subscriber
let's look at your photo he's an adult
with a stache and beard and shaved head
and I don't likes you interesting nobody
like fifteen-year-old kids asking for
shoutouts dude yeah if I'm gonna be
honest though serial killer vibe it's
cuz of a thin mustache and the eyes and
the face is probably just this photo
let's let's look at another photo hold
on he's making the same face yeah but
with the glasses he looks less serial
killer ish but the kind that like is a
serial killer who wears glasses to look
less suspicious is that a good faith in
personation yeah